how's it going everyone
this is International master Daniel
wrench this is chest comm and this is
the day we bring it all together you've
made it this far we are now in the
bottom of the ninth bases are loaded the
whole enchilada the big cheese
and that's enough silly references the
bottom line is that you've made it this
far you watch the first three videos and
everything you need to know video series
you now understand the critical
principles of all three stages of the
game and here we'd like to show you two
games two games that are considered a
couple of the greatest in history by a
couple of the greatest players in chess
history and hopefully what you'll see is
that all of the principles and things
you've learned can be put into action
they can be brought together to play a
complete and sometimes brilliant chess
game these games have been seen before
but what we are going to try to
highlight is that the principles and
things we've talked about we're a part
of these games and maybe will give you a
new light and a new perspective on what
happened and what took place in these
chess games the first one is the game
between Paul Morphy and the Duke of
Brunswick as well as count
Izu art I believe is how you pronounce
his name or Izu art this is the opera
game took place in Paris France in an
opera theatre house and it's a famous
chess game won because Paul Morphy was
known as one of the most principled and
best attacking chess players of all time
he was playing royalty and it was a
miniature in the sense of White's
approach to the game being just about
perfect and when he didn't run up
against the toughest defence it was an
ugly game and it was it was a very quick
game and a beautiful one from the
perspective of applying the principles
and things that we've learned before we
continue remind you that you can back up
and watch the other videos in this
series if you haven't already they're
completely free to all members here on
chess comm and so if there are principle
those are things that I reference in
this video that you're not completely
confident with even if you have watched
those videos I would strongly suggest
that you back up take a gander and then
come back and watch how we bring it all
together in this video here Paul Morphy
starts with E for considered one of the
most natural moves to start out
obviously both efore and D for a move
one being the most common approaches you
put a pawn in the center you fight for
the center and as we discussed in
principle number for bringing your
pieces out toward the center is where
they want to be not just developed
randomly and so he continues that by
bringing the knight out to attack the
pawn on e5 and black defends the pawn
already this is known as the Philidor
defense which was more popular before
the modern the theories of chess took
over I would say in the 20th century and
and they recognize that this is probably
a slightly passive approach for black
when compared to move to Knight to c6
but nonetheless we saw d6 and what's
important is not the blacks play was
perfect in this game that the two
players discussed the moves perfectly
but more so than morphe executed in a
high level manner that everybody can do
in their own games if they think about
the principles that we've talked about
here
he immediately challenges the center
because with the last move d6 one of the
reasons why the Philidor is considered
slightly pacifist is what it does to
blacks potential space and and fighting
power of the center blocking the bishop
white White has no reason not to be
aggressive and challenge the center
because of what black has done and here
black makes the first mistake a move
such as Knight to c6 again to defend the
pawn would have been better the move
Bishop g4 was played as it pins the
knight on f3
however after D takes e5 what black
quickly realized is that simply
capturing that the back the pawn would
allow a Queen trade on d8 followed by
the immediate win of the e5 pawn so a
black made the right decision rather
than just to lose the pawn but to
capture of three eliminate the knight
first and then capture back the problem
is that the immediate loss of the bishop
pair meaning the bishop on c8 for the
knight on f3 gives white an easy time
developing his own light square bishop
now what we notice is not only is white
developing therefore following the
principles of develop develop
development but also doing
with a purpose and tempo this isn't just
a trick going for the form of checkmate
but rather black and white is developing
the pieces with tempo and attacking of
seven with tempo makes a big difference
immediately we see that white though
white has the possibility here to cancel
short which would not have been a bad
move white recognizes that his opponent
having given up the bishop pair so early
and neglecting the development of the
kingside which usually is is preferred
here so the black and castle quickly in
doing so he opened up the possibility
for a four tactic white has the ability
to make a move that is a double attack
and that move is Queen to b3 attacking
both the f7 pawn as well as the
undefended b7 pawn now perhaps what's
most amazing about this move here is not
just that it's a fork but how he
followed up the next move after black
chose to play Queen e7 which already
shows that he's in dire straits because
he's willing to block this Bishop which
therefore blocks the rook which
therefore prevents castling black is
willing to make such a critical move
because he's hoping that white will
simply be settled on the pawn advantage
and allowed the Queen's to be traded
Morphy though who was a very principled
player and understood these features
perhaps and in a way in such a way that
was very ahead of his time those that
being the features I just highlighted
that blacks lack of development is
perhaps the bigger weakness in this
position then the then the b7 point is
perhaps the bigger problem for black is
the lack of development therefore
potentially weak King and in doing so
white played Knight to c3 exclaim of
iatch my favorite word for exclam a
great move that not only develops a
piece but prevents black from simply
escaping his his doom of a king in the
center and trading Queens he prevents
the the trade of Queens on b4 that would
have taken place once again after Queen
takes b7 check so after playing Knight
to c3 black now realizes that without
the ability to trade Queens allowing
this pawn to be captured followed by the
loss of a Brooke is is simply too much
to bear and c6 is played as a natural
move not only does c6 guard to b7 pawn
because it opens up the Queen but it
also guards a couple of critical squares
in the center so
good move by black-white now plays
Bishop to g5 notice that that's a pin so
that's the second tactic from our second
everything you need to know video that
we've seen today the first one being a
fork now we're seeing a pin in action
and notice that it's it's it's
interesting that these tactical patterns
are taking place while white is
developing this is not something chess
is not a game that can be broken down
into black and white in the sense that
you you try to think about everything in
terms of generalities and principles you
should think about all three of the
videos that you watched on the different
stages of the game as as one as one big
video as we said it's the one chess
lesson you need in your life and in this
situation where we bring it all together
in the climax video you see that you're
developing developing developing but
you're doing it with purpose and that
purpose which was mentioned the first
video can be things like forks and pins
so it all happens at a very early stage
and morphing understood that developing
his pieces aggressively to these sort of
tactical squares was a great idea and a
great way to put his opponent under
pressure now black probably should have
just focused on completing development
however he didn't want to based on the
loss of the b7 pawn and moving the Queen
one more time in order to try to open up
the bishop to get counseled also seemed
very slow instead of emphasizing those
points black thought he had an
opportunity to put back White's pieces
to kick them back a little bit so that
then he could refocus his efforts on
developing and the two players discussed
playing b5 the idea was simply to force
this bishop to retreat so that now there
would be less pressure on the f7 pawn
therefore allowing the Queen to move
which would therefore allow the bishop
to move you see the black needed all
these things to come together in order
to make up for the previous mistakes the
Queen cannot just move right away
because of pressure on on the f7 pawn
for example but but without the Queen
moving the bishop on f8 will not have
the ability to move and therefore the
King will never get cancelled so we see
that blacks problem sort of mounted up
what whereas White's were natural and
developing developing his pieces to the
right tactical squares and with tempo
and with purpose he's put black in this
in this very rough situation so black
played b5 to try to get his
way to kick whites bishop back and to
try to free up his pieces to get his
development complete and now we see the
climax white captured the b5 pond
sensing the opportunity to open the
position the key to whites ability to
sense that opportunity was that normally
the most accurate way to punish your
opponent's lack of development and
therefore their neglect of the King
safety is to open the center so though
his opponents may have been surprised by
this shot as we said Murphy's principles
led the way and he sensed the
opportunity for his pieces to take
control in terms of their activity and
for the tactics to work out well for
white after the move Knight B to d7
white continues to develop with tempo
bringing more pressure to the critical
squares and you'll notice completing the
principles of the opening as we talked
about connecting the rooks bringing it
together now black is in a tough
situation where all of white's activity
is simply overwhelming he played the
move rook to d8 which makes perfect
sense perhaps the only really natural
move to try to defend against White's
pressure however it simply was not
enough it was now time to put it away
and is in all games you can develop all
the principles you want and put all the
pressure on your opponent based on these
general fundamental and critical ideas
you've learned but at some point you
simply have to calculate and look for a
chance to deliver the knockout blow and
that's exactly what morphe does here
starting with the brilliant move rook
takes d7 winning the material back and
threatening a devastating discovered
check you see another one of our tactics
if this rook moves anywhere let alone
the fact that it's studying the Queen if
this rook moves anywhere it would be
opening up the bishop for check black
simply had to capture back and after the
other work joins the fight we highlight
one more time just how weak blacks
position is due to the lack of
development he tries to get out of it by
moving the Queen off so that the bishop
can finally develop unfortunately though
it was not enough to get out of the
forced checkmate that was about to be
had Bishop takes d7 the knight
recaptures back so as not to lose the AB
the Queen on e6 and after the brilliant
double exclaim of iatch Queen to be a
check black has no other move but to
capture on b8 with the knight
and white delivers the fatal blow rook
to DA checkmate though the final
position doesn't show many of the pieces
that were developed by white we saw that
the development of the pieces is what
led to this brilliant combination and
blacks extra material was not relevant
as the fact that his King is now
checkmated before move 20 we hope you
enjoyed this game and now let's move on
to our second example designed to help
highlight and show for you the
principles of the endgame in practice
though there are many incredible
champions in the history of our game who
have executed great endgame technique at
critical moments throughout their career
we chose a game played by often
considered one of the greatest endgame
players of all time that being the third
world champion josé raúl capablanca here
playing the white pieces against Rogozin
who is another very strong chess player
during that era well we plan to
highlight for you in this game are the
two critical principles that we taught
in yesterday's video here on chess calm
that being King activity and the
recognition and then execution of a
passed pawn though the past pawn on a3
is an obvious one
it is rather blockaded here with blacks
pieces strategically placed very well to
hold back the advancement of the
queenside pawns what we'd like you to
watch closely over the next few minutes
is how kappa blanka activates his King
keeps his pieces centralized and though
eventually does not push the a pawn
particularly to victory the constant
threat of advancing the a pawn allows
him to target other weaknesses in
black's camp eventually creating a
passed pawn on the other side of the
board white starts with the move f4 a
key moment for us to start this video
showing that the recognition that his
king is not active and in the game yet
was critical for kappa blanka and that
he would no longer wait to bring the
leader into the fight black tries to do
the same thing and when attacks the pawn
white simply defends and as both sides
develop a few more moves black realizes
he must keep his King back in order to
deal with the threats of discovered
check by his opponent white uses the
extra
time to activate his own king keeps the
pieces centralized and improves them
over the next few moves starting with
the king eventually bringing the knight
back to the critical square noted should
be the white is not worried about this
capture due to the discovered check and
therefore one of the rook the game
continues with what eventually making
the critical move here with King to c4
the threat being very simply to come to
b4 and begin advancing the a pawn
because of this black's time had run out
it was no longer an option to simply sit
on the position as White had clearly
broken down the blockade that this
Bishop and rook once held over the light
squares that blockade no longer existing
after the moves b5 and c4 and excuse me
king to c4 meant that black had to start
lashing out he played Bishop e6 check
and c5 check a move that black wouldn't
normally want to play as after simply
taking on passant white now has the loan
outside a pawn with no other challengers
on the Queen side and this bishop having
misplaced itself on the other side of
the board white now rather than simply
pushing the a pawn which would have also
won chose to keep the constant threats
against Blacks now newly created
weaknesses because black didn't want to
sit on the position and instead chose to
advance the pawns white begins creating
threats and over the next few moves you
will see that white targets the King
side along with keeping the constant
threat of pushing this pawn as an option
white brings the rook over to the King
side preparing to win more material and
after a few more moves we see that black
is completely stuck with the pieces
split in the sense that they must now
deal with one outside pass pawn along
with the passed pawn they've been
dealing with for the last several moves
after rook c8 rook g7 check and the
eventual defending against White's
possible loss of a piece with the move
rook to c4 after kappa blanka defended
that thread the game became very easy
and after h4 blacks
we resigned due to his inability to
create any more counter play with the
Brooke and Bishop and in turn without
counter play Black has no chance to stop
both of whites outside past pawns
note the King activity and the execution
of the extra pawns led to kept them like
this victory in this game we hope you
enjoyed the everything you need to know
video series in watching these videos
please recognize that knowledge of the
principles and the fundamentals can help
you to execute more powerful moves and
when you see how great champions brought
these principles together in their own
games hopefully you have the knowledge
and you are now psyched up to apply all
the things you've learned over the last
few days in your own games this has been
international master Daniel wrench for
chess comm and we will see you around